[Music]
damn this article
is extra sad to me because
as i was reading it it's um it was still
like an ongoing thing and i was excited
to like
see what the development was today yeah
and uh yeah it's not good so uh
upon reading it
boy
five years old uh in morocco he got
stuck at the bottom of a well
uh
for some reason it always happens to
kids but yeah this this kid fell down a
hundred foot well jesus christ and the
well had like a diameter of 17 inches oh
my god yeah really really tiny and he
was he'd been stuck down there for four
days
and uh damn that sucks and they had this
whole uh rescue operation to try to get
them out obviously they can't just like
you know put a rope send someone down
yeah you can't do that so they have to
dig
like kind of like adjacent to it
all the way down to where he is and then
dig this way
to try to get to him without the wall of
the well collapsing whoa
super super sensitive they couldn't just
dig this way huh yeah they just couldn't
do that there's no way because then
they'll just get you know the dirt's
gonna yeah there's a million ways you
could go wrong if they do it that way
they couldn't just find the biggest
chameleon they could find and have them
stick his tongue out down there and the
kid gets stuck to the tongue it's a good
idea that's really funny
in toontown yeah they would do that what
country this is in morocco no chameleons
there it was too dry lizards very small
so um damn where's rapunzel when we need
her dude yeah so it was like they had a
helicopter on standby for right when
they get him out it's gonna like take
him straight to the hospital all these
things were in place for everything to
go right and then like literally right
now as i opened it up uh the boy died oh
what the [ __ ] man yeah thanks uh does it
say that he died during the rescue part
of it like did the rescue part [ __ ] up
or did it was just didn't make it i
it's it yeah i think it says when they
got to him he wasn't making four days of
pain how did he survive that fall dude
they were sending food down and like
water down to him um yeah it's super
just like new right this second so uh
i don't even know if i can survive a day
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah i do i'm dead
you're just stuck down there it's dark
and it's cold they really tried to do
everything they could possibly do did
they know that he fell down there
immediately like the day of yeah and
then they try to figure [ __ ] yeah
because the boy's father i believe is
like working on the well and then uh the
boy was like kind of in the area with
his mom and then he just like wandered
off and and just went down yeah i
remember watching this video of this
dude he was walking down this like
grassy field and he didn't see this um
it was like a sewer
uh [ __ ] entry place right and then he
fell inside broke his bones couldn't get
back up and while he was down there
he just had to [ __ ] drink some sewer
water
[ __ ] a snake rolled by next to him he
had to bite that [ __ ] and eat it and
it was like some weird amount of time
that he just had to like lay there and
finally he heard some people walking by
and he like screamed
[Music]
and i'm like dude that is a [ __ ]
nightmare dude being stuck somewhere
yeah it's like that one movie where the
guy got stuck in between the ice and
[ __ ] or the the sand oh that's different
is that the sand the ice climber is it
though which one is it i thought you
talked about when he's arms stuck in the
cliff and he had to cut it off right
that's 127
was that in the desert or was that in
the ice it was in the desert it was in
the rocky uh hiking paths
i literally don't know i think i think
it was
desert okay okay well you asked this guy
about it
you don't want to watch that [ __ ]
because he takes tyco out there all the
time and always get worried you know
arizona you know just in those exact
cliffs where james franco was you know
looks like similar to rain you know yeah
it's kind of similar is it because he
fell he fell in his arms yeah and then
like it shift the rock like shift it
also like fell and stuff and then it
just clamped on his arm so he's stuck
there and he couldn't and the story is
you have to chop it
right
you stuck for how many days
127 hours yeah why they gotta make the
hours so big so it just feels longer
well divide that by 24 hours please i
don't know the [ __ ] five days and uh
what five and some change yeah some
change some change
five in a nickel less than a week
because it's not a big impact if you say
five days yeah it's weird it's five days
like five days four nights what is this
resort
you're really counting it by minutes
like because if you're stuck and that
was crazy because he had to cut his arm
off with something that was not very
sharp what do you do it with a blind
pocket knife yeah it was really [ __ ]
blind because the pocket knife would
would be short enough to go but then the
second you get to the bone and the
nerves
and they showed it in the movie in terms
of like the hardest part it's like the
nerves and he just left his arm there
yeah plus you're also like after like
you don't do that until the last resort
so he's already weak he's been drinking
his own urine he's hype like
hallucinating about [ __ ] there's no food
did he have morning wood still that's a
good question it's five days right you
might have five days in the morning wood
stuff these are the questions we should
have answered the q and a for winter
screening did you get morning wet on the
third date yeah we should ask this
question so we can get thrown out of the
screening
but what if he's like no no i'll answer
it no i'm so glad you asked let him ask
the question
bring him back
the guy's there he's just kind of like
well i mean it's legitimate
man-to-man tell me the truth yeah they
need to have a man-to-man section at q
and a's they should huh hey uh
from jk news man of man
it's a man-to-man question man-to-man
all right stand down for those five days
how many times did you jack off what do
you think the actual answer is all the
men in the room yes please answer you
thought about it he's like first of all
i loved uncle chen
[Laughter]
big fan uncle trent big big [ __ ] fan
i didn't even know
during about 20 minutes it was 127 hours
i definitely had a couple chuckles
thanks to you
did you just watch it imagine watching
jk [ __ ] films didn't call for help
he used his only bar of wi-fi for that
moment he saved it he had it saved
camera roll i mean for five days you
gotta keep yourself busy somehow what
are you gonna do fondle yourself i don't
know you know okay
i mean i do it when i i you think about
it you have to dehydrate yourself more
well okay i didn't think about you're
stuck somewhere for five days what do
you do especially if you have anxiety
jacking off is one of the best things to
do when you have anxiety what if he did
it to fall asleep you're gonna do i just
okay it's a good question for the room
though like he's using something you
were stuck in the boulder which you've
jerked off
how do we find ourselves back here
that'll be fine
i'd be afraid i'd pass out
come on what's sad is like that
situation of uh you know the franco dude
being stuck in a boulder a million times
better than being in a well that's 17
inches
that i don't know i don't want to be in
the belly of a snake you know yeah
that's this is
like 15 inches so it's like like a
little bit but the kit is probably like
14 inches so dude that's so sad yeah
that's a nightmare dude right i mean at
least this other dude had options yeah
yeah 100 feet down is a long long way
down 100 [ __ ] yeah that's like almost 10
stories yeah the kid fell 100 feet down
he fell 100 feet down so he's probably
got like existing injuries that are
of course like
he might be bleeding and turtle bleeding
there's water there too obviously and
they were they weren't even sure if like
they were letting food down but they had
no way of knowing if he was like eating
it or not well they can't be like oh did
you get a food
can i get a grilled cheese they could
actually hear him like uh i think they
could hear him crying oh [ __ ] don't give
me the [ __ ] real feelings i know
yeah it's really like super tragic but
this is why we have to talk about
jacking off because it's just
i was like so excited to be because like
it all had such a good outlook i was
like oh it's gonna be dope when i come
to the office and then the update is
that he's like out and he's wearing a
blanket everything you think you're
going to see
and nothing they just were like he
didn't make it how many movies do in
real life end in a
like sad story well at least some of
it's like half and half like the chilean
miners one remember like that one was
like tell me about that one is it a good
story yeah they say yeah most of them
right most of them what what about the
the the thai soccer team the kid boys
oh the boss that got uh they were stuck
underground somewhere did they get like
some like special operations scuba guys
or something one guy died trying to save
him though didn't he yeah that's right
he was the guy that saved them and he
died yeah but the kids were safe though
yeah yeah they saved the kids i saw a
bus
so africa was flooding right and then
this bus driver
went over this bridge that had river
water going over it and i guess he was
just like i don't give a [ __ ] let's go
you know and then as he was going the
bus got pushed by the river water and it
went into the river
in less than 10 seconds that [ __ ] just
went to the ground and only three people
swam out of it it was a full bus
and i just hear people going oh my like
they're not not oh my god but they're
like screaming and yelling like and then
you see
people trying to go and run after it and
then you see people trying to climb out
of the window and only a couple people
made it out and i was like
that i just witnessed like in less than
10 seconds a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of
people drowned to death crazy dude
imagine if like an opening is not easy
enough to access waters pushing you up
the bodies are trying to scramble
because you don't think in orderly
fashion yeah
and how many people can actually swim
yeah like you don't know and to be able
to think effectively yeah the water
might not might be murdered through all
these [ __ ] bodies and [ __ ] not like
there's chlorine to have it clear enough
if you have a window of time to probably
get out plus there's like the first like
minute where you're in disbelief and
shock of what's going on
not thinking of escape yeah the water's
cold and [ __ ] like
yeah
because if you don't even start holding
your breath immediately it's like what
that's
like it's gonna be fun
oh my god i hate when yeah that's it it
was a muddy water too it's not clear
yeah you're not gonna see [ __ ] dude as
soon as you get out it's all [ __ ]
like it's all chocolate milk so you
can't even go and help anybody oh you
can't see nothing yeah well i'm glad we
changed the subject yeah thanks guys
it reminded me of something sad this is
the [ __ ] saddest jk news episode ever
dude okay why though okay
127 hours i'll jack off every day
yeah anthony let's go end the video
[Music]
you